i did this thing where i walked on my
toes
and it's like it's like a normal thing
like i've done it since i was a kid
oh don't do that
even if you can do it don't you're like
walking right on the joint wow
i keep seeing these posts about health
care workers coming home and avoiding
contact with their families completely
or taking off their scrubs before
walking into their house so that they
don't spread anything to them
but i personally feed my scrubs to my
children every day that i come home from
work
because i didn't raise a family of
amberlynn
what just happened that was the most
aggressive tick tock is that a joke
yeah you should absolutely take off your
scrubs before you see your family
and take a shower like the first thing i
do when i come home is like
shower time she said i feed it to my
children i was like oh my god
megan just asked me have you ever
twerked
to orchestra
this is amazing not only because she's
truly twerking
to classical orchestra music but because
they're clearly having fun at work and
we need a little bit more of that i also
have so many videos just like this for
my residency days
[Music]
things that don't belong in your body
part four part four
i wanna see parts one through three
i'm fairly sure dumbbells don't belong
in the human body the weirdest ones i've
seen
pipe cleaners like you know those little
furry ones when you're a kid in a mail
and uh carrot i'll leave it at that hey
becky i just wanted to check in with you
are
you doing okay do you need anything who
me
no i'm fine it's actually kind of quiet
today
oh my gosh you got busy i've said it
time and time again you did not say the
q
word it's funny that i'm getting all
stressed out about it when i was the guy
oh it's kind of quiet
ten rapid responses four admissions two
code blues
they took like the most gangsta driving
thing i don't even know
what competition this is they put piggy
noises in the back
soap is an amazing substance oh bill nye
the science guy we by the way became
quite close friends at the men in black
premiere we actually
tried to get him on the youtube channel
we're still making that happen maybe you
guys can exert some forces
some gravitational like physical forces
and encourage him to come on the channel
each soap molecule is like a string with
one end that sticks to water and the
other end that sticks to oil or
fat so take a look at this this string
floating on water represents a coronal
virus molecule watch what happens
when we touch the surface of the water
with this bar of soap
three two one
the molecule falls apart that's why
you've gotta wash your hands wash your
hands
wash your hands
take that virus molecule
just so everyone knows that sound effect
is not actually what's happening when
you wash your hands can you imagine
how noisy bathrooms would be
but yes soap does destroy the membrane
thereby killing
viruses bacteria and the added benefit
of washing your hands with soap and
water getting rid of foreign residue
dirt and things like that that moment
when your doctor's office calls you and
says oh my goodness we're so sorry we
forgot the extra screening that you
requested can you come in and do a urine
sample for us
and then you say the extra screening i
requested and they say yes
you wanted an std test for chlamydia and
then you say
i'm pretty sure i don't have chlamydia i
did not request that
and then they say uh-oh that shouldn't
happen if a
patient of the same name came in at the
same time
and there wasn't the name alert given
either by the system or by the staff
you have called back patients
incorrectly and that can get
very very problematic because as you
know healthcare information is a
protected asset
this is the honest truth behind social
media by the way
look they always look so glamorous and
they're never tired like dr mike how do
you come home from night shifts and
look like you're wide awake i don't i
come home and i crash
i need a tick tock doctor
look at it it's so weird and
inconsistent
when you're constantly typing especially
sitting in that non-ergonomic position
where your hand is cocked backwards like
that it's quite uncomfortable and as a
result when you overuse a muscle
especially one that's under trained
you can cause spasms cramps and they
happen just like that
[Music]
nowhere in the world in legitimate
medical schools do we teach that
himalayan salt lamps can do
anything outside of maybe look kind of
cool in your bedroom decor because you
know you want a light but you also want
to show that like
you're with it you're with the geo
you're like a geo person to not
go on a journey looking to boost your
immune system if you have a normal
healthy immune system the
definition of homeostasis in a normal
immune system is one that is not
boosted because a boosted immune system
is an
autoimmune condition where your body is
so boosted it starts attacking itself
don't boost it okay
just take me to my room
sometimes i look at my nurses or cmas
and they're bringing patients in and
sometimes they're like
letting the like they're being polite so
they say like go right ahead for the
patient to walk into the general area
then the patient has no idea where to go
truth to bad sunscreen sunscreen is
poison guys do not use sunscreen
okay so this is the truth now no it's
not light-skinned people are not
supposed to burn the sun
when i was younger i would burn the sun
now i never burn i get five to six hours
of sun
every day i try to at least okay so
this is the key you have to change what
you're eating what you're eating if it's
acidic based
and all that junk food and garbage and
all that meat it's gonna make it so your
skin burns in the sun
if you switch to organic fruits and
vegetables you're not gonna burn in the
sun anymore
i feel like he's burned right now like
what is he talking about do not even
experiment with this
if you go outside you will get a sunburn
if you're in the right place
with the sun hitting you for an extended
period of time and guess what with each
burn that you have
you are more likely to develop a skin
cancer and one of the most deadly and
scary
skin cancers are melanomas well if you
get a melanoma and you don't catch it
and it spreads melanoma spreads to the
most random of places
muscles bones liver your eyes
your neurological system please wear
your sunscreen
and don't listen to jimmy b rose tv or
whoever this is
uh we want nice steady compressions
what look at trap that's cpr that'll
save a life
oh thanks i used to be a lifeguard
[Applause]
what did you do i don't know you were
too
good at cpr i wonder if i did my chest
compressions chest compression chest
compressions can i bring the dummy back
to life
i actually prank doctors click here to
check that out
like legit like you're gonna see their
faces
they got pranked mama dr jones in it
spoiler alert but click it to check it
out as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]